Once again I have updated the graph class. So now it shows the old graph that we
have this original problem, the orange one. And then above that, the new graph
that we have of the equation, y equals negative 7x squared plus 14x. Thinking
back to how we settle the problem at first, we say that we should let the base
of the fountain be situated at the origin. This is why we wanted one of the
roots of our equation to be 0. So you can see that we've got the fountain lined
up right here. This is where the water is spouting out from. Now, my question is
how far from the base of the fountain will the water land? Assume that
everything here is measured in meters. So figure out what point on a curve
corresponds to the place where the water from the fountain hits the ground, and
then, figure out how far away from the base of the fountain that is?